what is your biggest concern today we
have biden as a president kamado as a vp
trump's been banned facebook's not going
to return the ban for a couple years
twitter's not going to do that
we're in a very interesting time we're
living in to the point where
you're getting bill maher and people
like russell brand to start jon stewart
just like questioning
the fact that this was a man-made virus
just three months ago if that would have
been said on stephen colbert
they would have been banned their show
would have been banned but today it's
like going back to it so
what do you see as your biggest concern
today in america
those are all wonderful things in this
not all of them if it's
really great if you have an entity
whether it's
a girlfriend boyfriend or the media in
it can you imagine like you're dating
someone
and she tells you for a year baby i'm
loyal baby i'm loyal baby i'm loyal
and then you find the photographs of her
with some dude she's never going to be
able to unring that bell
even if you guys work it out that will
still always be that this is not the
person i thought
this is something she's capable of so to
have the media which for decades had a
monopoly
on public discourse in this country
until you had talk radio
then you had cable news like starting
with cnn i think in 1980
uh now you have social media when you
have these outlets
like cnn fox new york times
insisting that they're telling you the
truth with the straight face
and then it all collapses very quickly
when jon stewart
who's not exactly some kind of alt-right
conservative republican
is saying here's the thing let's suppose
john
i don't remember exactly what he said
but let's suppose he's wrong
the idea that we shouldn't be discussing
for future reference man-made viruses
how we would handle it what it would
look like if it got out
is insane that was what they were having
us
banned for and you are never going to be
able to regain the trust of the
population
you asked me earlier how we get to
anarchism this is how
the people who are in positions of
ostensible authority
demonstrate through their own depravity
of malfeasance
that not only are they mistaken which
they're going to be
which you're gonna be which i'm gonna be
a lot but
they don't care and they're going to
continue
uh with these uh mistakes they're not
mistakes i think they're just blatant
lies and shutting down our conversations
it is very very hard if you're if your
brand is truth and trust and you've been
demonstrated
to be dishonest and untrustworthy to get
people to return to your brand
i think it's very asymmetric in that
regard how do they how did they keep
existing though how did they keep
inertia uh how do they keep existing how
do they keep
being around and relevant and still
getting the eyeballs that they're
getting obviously i know
they're i know all the numbers who's
down who's up all that stuff how are
they still as relevant today and i'm
talking specifically media
yeah it's it's inertia if you look at
that friend you just mentioned
the one who gained 80 pounds i'm just
going to use him as shorthand i don't
mean him specifically
but if he's grown up you know watching
cbs at the dinner table with mom and dad
he's never going to
he doesn't want the choice he's like
this is something my parents watched
it's innocuous it's not upsetting me i
am learning the information
i am the person to screen seems very
respectable and smart
i'm just gonna stick with this for the
you know the rest of my life so for that
population the blue pill people
they're they're not going to change what
i care about
are the people from all sides of the
political aisle and those of us who
reject politics entirely
who are capable of critical thoughts be
like oh these are really nefarious
malevolent
actors the the agencies and we have to
find ways to both mitigate their power
and to create alternative paths to
information than going through them
because at the very least even if they
were angels
they're still filtering the information
that i might otherwise find of use
and any filter as you have a tech
background knows you're going to be
letting in things you don't want
and you're going to be keeping out
things that you do this basic ab
test so uh that is something i think
it's very healthy so if you like this
sort of short clip from an interview i
did click over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye